peu la maman du groupe moitié range tout
l'idée de départ
l'heure est venue pendant le confinement
il se lance alors dans la construction
d'un bateau entièrement recyclée
quelques palettes des bidons de récup et
un manuel de fabrication sur internet et
voilà leur fière embarcations c'est
gauthier qui a chapeauté le chantier
c'est la première fois que je vais
entreprendre de construire quelque chose
pareil donc je suis assez content de ce
que j'ai fait sous le coffre
c'était extrêmement compliquée avec
saint leu leu leu repose là on may not
do la banquette est un peu en incliné
dans la 45 degrés donc c'était compliqué
à faire devraient naviguer plus de 200
kilomètres sur la loire mais attention
même en eux par courant qu'une dizaine
de kilomètres par jour
le fleuve royal et tumultueux la loire
de temps en temps on passe de 2,3 mètres
de fond à 20 cm donc on doit souvent
sortir du radeau certains de pouce donc
on sait changer un peu les rôles on doit
paquet pagayer changer les directions le
vent aussi comme on va vraiment pas vite
on va de kilomètres heure le moindre
vent nous fait reculer donc donc souvent
c'est un peu compliqué il faut toujours
regarder toujours faire attention à
l'origine c'était un défi sportif
mais le groupe dème veut aussi donner du
sens à son périple
ce sera celui du patrimoine et de la
culture ils sont même parrainé par le
journaliste stéphane bern qui les
rencontrera à l'issue du voyage tous les
châteaux qu'on visite on a des rendez
vous avec les conservateurs les
directeurs qui nous parlent de leur
château de leur passion qui nous
explique comment il faut face à la
pandémie
et puis on rencontre des vignerons les
bouchers les artisans ont fait des
dégustations on a déjà rencontré
plusieurs vignerons des brasseurs
donc on vraiment beaucoup de monde oui
le couteau voyager lentement c'est aussi
l'occasion de se faire plaisir en route
et ça n'est pas fini
ce soir les cinq garçons sont reçus par
des vignerons
[Musique]